بعد شبه جزيره القرم ها هو الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين يصل الى ماريوبول على متن
مروحيه وبشكل مفاجئ في المدينه التي سقطت
في يد الروس في ايار مايو العام الماضي
تجول بوتين بسياره قديمه تولى قيادتها ثم
توجه الى حين فسكي الجديد الذي بناه الجيش
الروسي والطلعه على مشروع اعاده اعمار
المدينه المدمره
وسط المدينه بشده نحن نعمل على انهاء
عمليه اعاده البناء بحلول نهايه العام على
الاقل وسط هذه المدينه جميل جدا
جنائيه
توقيف بحق الرئيس الروسي بتهمه ارتكاب
جريمه حرب لترحيل الاف الاطفال
الاوكرانيين خلال النزاع لم يمنع بوتين من
السفر الى المناطق التي احتلتها قواتها
العسكريه وتفقد منازل العائلات وكذلك
الساحل ماريوبول بعد احياء ذكرى التاسعه
لضم شبه جزيره القرمه لكن الرئيس الروسي
اختتم جولته سريعا بالتوجه الى مدينه
روستوفيه حيث التقى القياده العليا
المسؤوله عن العمليه العسكريه في الداخل
الاوكرانيه زياره تزمرت مع تكثيف القصف في
عدد من المناطق الاوكرانيه ككراماتورس في
شرق البلاد التي امطرتها روسيا بالذخائر
العنقوديه المحظوره وفق حاكم منطقه
دوناتسك تحضر اكثر من مئه دوله استخدام
الذخائر العنقوديه لكن روسيا تواصل
استخدام هذه الاسلحه التي تطلق الكثير من
القنابل الصغيره وتصيب المدنيين عشوائيا
استهداف المدينه
للمياه هذا الاسبوع ادى الى تضرري نحو 12
مبنى سكنيا و14 منشات تابعه للبلديه
ومقتدى وجرح عدد من المدنيين